If you think that much of anything related
to politics will be settled by Tuesday's election,
here's some bad news for you: Nothing that
matters is really over.
"Nothing is over!
Nothing!"
There are at least three major issues facing
the country
when either President Clinton or President Trump gets sworn in next January.
You may not realize it, but the U.S. has been
out of recession for seven years.
But the average rate of growth since 2009
has been around 2 percent,
making this the weakest economic recovery since 1949.
Economic growth is essential to improving
living standards,
and it helps to defuse all sorts of explosive political issues,
from trade to immigration to welfare.
But for all of the 21st century economic growth
has been much lower than what we're used to.
Neither Clinton or Trump has put forth a plan
that will actually grow the economy.
Clinton will jack up taxes and spending on
everything,
a sure-fire way to keep the economy sputtering along.
Trump will add more than five-trillion dollars
to the national debt,
which will also dampen growth.
Hillary Clinton is a hawk's hawk who has voted
for, lobbied for, or taken credit for
all of our military interventions in the 21st
century.
Despite such actions—or more accurately,
BECAUSE of such actions—the world is a mess.
At times Donald Trump sounds like he would
be a relative dove
and at others, he sounds like a crazy man;
at the very least, like Hillary Clinton, he said that he would increase military spending.
Neither of them has articulated a foreign
policy
that will help reduce international terrorism,
or bring order and peace to hot
spots in the Middle East, Eastern Europe,
or Asia any time soon.
Trust and confidence in most American institutions
are at or near historic lows
—the media, religious organizations, labor, business—you name it.
That's especially true when it comes to the
two major political parties
and government in general.
Even worse, millennials aren't just the biggest
generation, they are the most skeptical.
Who can blame them—or us?
The Iraq War was sold on bad information and
prosecuted poorly;
President Obama's claims that his health care reform would let you keep your doctor
was the Lie of the Year in 2013,
and we've learned that Democrats and
Republicans don't give a rat's ass
about the government spying on us.
Wikileaks and others have exposed Hillary
Clinton as two-faced at best
and Donald Trump is a serial scam artist and bully.
Neither will address the massive and ongoing
evacuation of trust and confidence
in government and politics.
If anything, they will likely pour gas on
this dumpster fire.
This means America is moving rapidly from a high-trust society to a low-trust one
and that's really bad news,
especially for those of us who want
a government that spends less and does less.
Why? because paradoxically,
people in low-trust
countries turn to government in ever-higher numbers.
In a cruel and unpredictable world, they want
a protector, no matter how untrustworthy.
Politicians and their supporters can act responsibly
and put forth serious plans for reducing the size, scope and spending of government.
Gary Johnson and Bill Weld did precisely this.
The two former governors spoke not of zero government
but of smaller government
that did fewer things more effectively.
Such characters are few and far between
but there are enough elected officials in each party
to at least insist on government performing
its basic functions.
Such as passing actual budgets each year.
Until the major parties start governing in
the light of day
and especially stop nominating candidates who are distrusted by majorities of Americans,
don't expect much to change.
Except for things to get even nastier.